mr malice yeah did you see what um
marjorie taylor green recently said
about vaccine passports uh
the bark of the beast the mark of the
box i predicted that you predicted what
that christian fundamentalists are going
to start invoking the mark of the beast
not incorrectly about these vaccines not
incorrectly yes
this is the craziest thing because i
didn't know this until someone super
chatted us
that the mark of the beast was literally
saying you couldn't buy or sell
without it yeah i didn't know that when
i grew up you didn't read revelation
no no no no no no yeah
yes yeah yeah kindergarten till end of
fifth grade i was in capital seven heads
and ten horns
yeah yeah and it rose from the lake or
whatever something i read it recently
and uh i think it was several months ago
someone mentioned on the show that the
prophecies are starting to come true
they're always starting i know i know
and so i actually did it i did a segment
on it for my main channel people have
been more
are more immoral now than they've ever
been yeah
people are saying that like the prophecy
of the lady with this this stuff before
babylon yeah yeah they're like it's
venus and the moon and whatever and it's
like you're looking for patterns like
you were just saying a moment ago you
look for patterns humans are really good
at this
what's that thing that that's called
where you're like look at it you can see
this yeah i forgot
it's called paradilia or something like
that you can see a face and everything
and so people post these photos on the
internet
so i do think it's really interesting
though that
the vaccine passport uh you'll need it
to buy and trade
and now you've got obviously certain
individuals saying could this be the
mark of the beast
could it be no no it's not
it's a bad idea regardless of the mark
of the beast uh and
the problem is i i i i'm a fan of hers
because i like anyone who's a loon who
says things that are just
it's much more effective to get your
position across in politics
if you come across as unreasonable than
if you're trying to sit down and have a
discussion really why do you say
because there's no talking to her right
so she's not going to sit down with
aoc and they're not going to co-sponsor
legislation right that's never going to
that's never going to happen but the ioc
wouldn't do it either but that's of use
to the republican party
when they're coming off as intransigent
because then the democrats
this happened twice it happened during
the gingrich congress uh in in 94 95
this happened during the debt ceiling
crisis under obama and the republicans
like we're not raising that secret
crisis and we might have to default
those are the only two times they got
budgetary concessions
from the democrats so it's a very useful
thing to come off as
or actually be uh yeah
that's what a lot of people were saying
about donald trump right when it came to
foreign policy
people were like you can't negotiate
with this guy because you know he's out
of it
and so that put pressure on these four
these other world leaders where it's
like what do you do when you have to
negotiate for the best of your country
and you're with donald trump was gonna
go excuse me no no
i don't know what that is we're not no
no no and you're like i
do what do i say he just takes it's one
of the reasons people really like the
guy
but i suppose it's a good point now to
be fair i think aoc isn't going to be
you know uh coming to the table for the
democrats either
so marjorie taylor green like i said
comes off like a loon
aoc is not going it's effectively doing
the same thing for democrats so
that's not you don't think so i don't i
i don't i don't think that's the same
thing i don't think
aoc is saying well no you're right you
know what because she is saying the
republicans are changing the weather
and the climate change so i just take it
back yeah okay i'm right i was wrong
look she said under donald trump these
are concentration camps yeah
so we we not we can see it's funny how
they demonize marjory taylor green and
i'm like yo
you guys had aoc first so you don't get
to come out and complain about margery
taylor green now
i can i can certainly point out marjorie
taylor green's posts on facebook and she
apologized for these things
she did she walked it all back i don't
okay i don't let's talk about that
okay if you say that the rothschilds are
building lasers
to change the weather i get how you
you're sorry you said it
yeah but i don't get is walk me through
how you got there
and why you no longer are going there
that's what i want to know
i don't need apology so are you saying
that it's quite possible that she's just
saying that she really still believes in
the space lasers changing the weather i
if you believe that space lasers changed
the weather as is your prerogative
what changed your mind al roker now hold
on a second
there there there was uh several studies
done where they used infrared lasers
to uh a seat a cloud seating for for
cloud seating
okay that actually happened sure i guess
the issue is when you claim the
rothschilds we're doing it you know
instead of like it was like a university
of berlin or something was like hey we
just realized this thing happens when
you point laser to the
tin foil pool no no i i just think it's
like
we what you need to understand about the
insidiousness of these conspiracy
theories is how they
they come from a little seed of truth oh
of course and then someone pours
gatorade on them because that's what
plants crave and then
then they end up with some wacky idea
they can't figure out why things aren't
working properly
and also in their defense we've all
played telephone right
so i can't tell you the number of times
when someone reads an article
and then they'll just repeat it and it's
like that's not what the article said at
all
i've had people accuse me because i
wrote a book called the new right
of portraying myself as having invented
it i'm like
what are you perceiving me having said
that that you're getting to this
conclusion
yeah other than the rothschilds put
lasers in your brain but look look
i think aoc holds i i think it's fair to
point out thinking about space lasers
from the rothschilds for weather control
is like
very much out there for sure it's out in
space here's the problem it's silver
the democrats believe often many equally
as insane things
sure chris hayes has on a guy on his
show on msnbc
is it possible that donald trump has
been a russian asset since the late 80s
and they don't even stop to think that
would imply that trump was still working
for the soviet union which doesn't exist
so who is the asset for you know about
that right but i don't think that's as
crazy as space lasers to be honest it's
not
what i'm saying is well i mean that's
fairly crazy
you want to we'll have we'll have a
crazy off and calculate and quantify
what no it's
come on wait what what's what's more
crazy that one person has been corrupted
or that they're changing the weather for
secret
purposes i don't think those are
comparable in terms of lunacy
uh and also putin was a kgb agent so
there's
there was a lot of there was a lot of
continuity between for sure absolutely
absolutely no one's denying that uh we
have satellites
we have satellites with lasers we can
use infrared lasers for cloud seeding we
use silver was it silver iodide for
clouds oh maybe yeah i thought of silver
nitrate might be
nitrate i could be wrong silver nitrate
there's a silver they use the point is
if you had to play roulette and the
choices are
donald trump has been a russian agent
and the rothschilds are firing lasers to
change the climate
you're saying it's a coin toss no okay
i'm saying that they're both really
crazy and i understand why you think one
is crazier than the other because it
certainly is okay
but i'm also pointing out what they do
is they take morsels of truth to create
this like of course
it's a lot easier to manipulate with
some basis and truth than just something
pure fabrication
1619 project is fabricated garbage and
the left
believes this aoc believes this stuff
it's a creation myth right
right she puts this stuff in policy so
again i i get it i don't
i i'm sorry interrupt you because i
won't i'm going to be pedantic
i don't we don't know that she believes
it it could just certainly be of use to
her
i agree no i i think you're right i just
mean that
she uses it yeah so uh this is the point
i was gonna bring up before
under trump she's like these are
concentration camps under biden she
literally said there's no
there's no border crisis and it's
different now because biden is trying to
solve the problem
it's worse than it was under trump it's
not the most amount of migrants
but reuters even said we are looking at
a 20-year spike
in in in these these unaccompanied
minors and illegal
illegal immigrants we got new video from
project veritas
children in the dirt under a bridge at
near mcallen
it is bad what they don't want to talk
about because no one knows how to wrap
their heads around this i saw
some there's some articles that mention
this but it's not being made into a
bigger deal and i think it really should
be
people talk about rape culture there is
a lot of sexual assaults in these
uh when you have lots of people who are
not have not citizens who have no
access to the legal system who you don't
know who the heck they are
they're locked in in close confinement
with other people
like in a prison you're going to have
large numbers of assaults and that to me
is what i find extremely disturbing
and if you actually were concerned about
these people who are being held in these
locations
that should be your priority number one
and it's not and that to me is
very very sick let me ask you something
do you believe marjorie taylor green
genuinely believed those things she was
saying yes
do you think aoc genuinely believes the
things she's saying no which would you
prefer in government
i would prefer um i can't say what i
prefer regarding government because we
get banned
that's fair all right just like we won't
go to the moon with it
but if you're like looking at two people
and you're like you can have the person
who's lying or the person who's crazy
what do you do
i would rather have the person who's
lying because the person who's lying is
still
aware of reality and acting in
accordance with it whereas the person
who's crazy
it is a bell curve and if you go for
standard deviations
you might have things like nuclear war
or really so yeah i i agree because
the point i want to get to is with a
liar like aoc if she was given unlimited
resources
she would implement some really wacky
crazy system where she tries to pander
to her base sure
but at least they would it would be like
health care that people just kind of are
upset with
or you know generally bad things that
still exist in reality
if you took someone who's absolutely
crazy and i'm not trying to imply
margaret taylor would do this but
if you had somebody who believed that
there was like you know nazis on the far
side of the moon with unlimited
resources they would get us building
rockets to the moon to go fight people
who aren't there
and that would just i might rather have
rockets to the moon than like socialized
healthcare because less people are dying
we'll see so now you've made the
argument for the other case exactly
the point i'm making is that you could
have a crazy person just build crazy
things
i don't know maybe they nuked the moon
aoc what are just someone
yeah what are you gonna do guys sitting
around they're gonna expire at some
point
so maybe it's not so easy because the
liar is going to make a broken system
and they do the politicians they're just
like how can we make everyone happy i
don't know give them universal health
care that they got to pay for so they
get the individual mandate
here's the easy one that the republicans
are fiscal responsibility they never
vote for a smaller budget that's a very
blatant explicit line
right well you get liars you get crazy
people and sometimes you get both
i think we have both what's the i don't
know i guess
your solution is what just like anarchy
yeah
it's not empowering crazy people and
liars
have you what the power of police i was
thinking we could get rid of
representatives and just use smart
contracts that we vote for
as a collective so why do we have to
vote on anything hmm so that we can
agree without having because some talk
to each other but because sometimes
rivers start on fire
sure rivers start on fire because the
property right of that river isn't being
protected
who the the people owned the river well
that's not a thing
people can't oh who are the pew people
it's like that's people who live there
that's the tragedy of the commons is
that when
no one owns it then no one feels
responsibility for it and then everyone
just takes whatever resources they can
and it becomes destroyed
i just i just i there's there's a
logical hole here when i have these
conversations
with like libertarians and objectivists
about owning water
it's like so you're from the cuyahoga
river you're owning water right there
right i'm talking about like a river
apparently river caught on fire again
last year what really yeah someone just
told me about it in kyogre falls
let's talk about let's talk about
pollution because this is a this is
there's no system where this isn't a
complicated issue
so let's be reasonable here if let's
compare china to the us
uh the chinese river dolphin the goddess
of the river which has been a symbol of
china for for centuries has now gone
extinct wow uh the
chinese paddlefish which i think is the
second or the largest
freshwater fish has now gone extinct uh
the
the pollution when you have a uh heavy
centralized economy
which leads to poverty means that
government now is trying to pull
resources from whatever it can because
otherwise the people are starving
so when you have a bougie society a
whole food society
those are the ones who care and have the
ability and wealth
to preserve uh the environment to
preserve things like river
rivers but i agree with you no no
environmentalist
or anyone on earth is going to have an
easy solution when you're talking about
water which moves
and you know it's upstream upstream and
weather and things like that yeah have
you ever seen
i actually otherwise other than having a
culture where this is revered and
something that people care about
so i'm i'm i'm very much in favor of
environmental regulations
um i i don't i don't know if the
solutions to the world are always going
to be easy or as clear-cut but uh
have you ever seen this video it's by i
think it's youtube channel called gray
still plays i think it's called
where it's a game i think it's called
city state okay and
he decided to just make it pure anarchy
and he thought it was going to be a
bunch of wealthy oligarchs and a bunch
of poor people and drugs and gangs and
this video
he's a really funny youtuber it's really
it's a really really great video because
he's shocked by what happens
and so you watch him play the game and
you watch the game played by other
people and they're like i think we need
environmental regulations okay
let's make sure we have housing for the
poor and you get a mix of poverty and
pollution and you're fighting to keep
things going
so he decides he's gonna have no
regulations no taxes and let people do
whatever he want
and as the game progresses there's no
poverty anymore
everyone's living in luxury and he's
going what's happening
it literally says like it's like
capitalist oligarchy
and there's no poor people everyone's
homes are being built there's ski
resorts everywhere
he's like why are there so many ski
resorts yeah but the poor people have
been made into cold cuts
yeah yeah no no just now they have value
the funny thing is i guess the response
you get from the left is that the game
was clearly made by a capitalist
but in this signal all games are made by
capitalists it's a game it's not a gulag
exactly i just think leisure is a
function of capitalism
um yeah yes fine explain come on
what do you need to explain communists
don't play baseball
no first of all baseball no baseball is
a west western contrivance but the point
is when you have a contrivance it is
they think it's a waste of time because
it's not working for the culture and and
i i forget why they specifically hated
baseball but maybe because it was too
american
but yeah when you have these states
where you're supposed to be working for
your fellow man
any spare time that means that's time
you're taking away from poor people and
hungry people you don't need to be
working they particularly attributed
leisure to specialization
yeah which came from capitalism you know
that in north korea there are people
whose job is to be a skateboarder
i've never heard of north korea never
heard of it no so there's this place
it's a uh it's part of a peninsula you
mean like an island
a place it's not an island it's a
peninsula okay all right and the
northern part
is you know basically it's communist and
but uh in this place there are people
who are
told they have to skate every day by the
government are they competitive
competitive yeah and so they compete you
know i i guess it's the idea
i don't know that they have the ability
or i'm not entirely sure
i've just seen the photos and like i've
read in skateboarding magazines about
the communists who are like mandated to
be skateboarders well let me break this
down a little bit because as you guys
know i wrote a book on north korea dear
reader
so it's not i mean this is something
that's taken a little bit out of
context athletes in a country that's as
poor as north korea as small as north
korea
is a great way to have reverence on the
world stage because they're saying look
we're tiny north korea we're the size of
well they wouldn't use this example the
size of pennsylvania
and we're taking on russia we're taking
on the united the you know wicked
the wicked u.s imperialist and the [ __ ] i
can't even finish the sentence because
it's a slur
so this is a great and also if you're
coming from nothing now it's your chance
to be a hero of the entire
nation so they are very this is a big
thing during the olympics with the cold
war
this is a very uh common mechanism for
these states cuba
uh i talk to people who know people in
the ufc who think they engage in these
kind of super soldier
experiments on kids uh to make these
athletes who are later growing up to be
ufc fighters
because this is their and east german
the east german women's swim team we're
all on a certain type of steroid
and they ask the coach they go why'd
they all have such deep voices
and the coach said they came here to
swim not to sing
this was the quote so this is very
common in these
uh centralized countries where you are
basically becoming a hero because it's
kind
it's not expensive to become a great
skateboarder well don't you think that
there's a
i'm surprised that skateboarding is a
thing there to be honest because that's
such a capitalist
bougie thing it's entering the realize
olympics
skateboarding was the olympic event well
it's it's i think the first it's it's
first olympic event is going to be
coming up in china okay that's why okay
and over the past decade it's been a
huge point of contention for
skateboarders because
i mean skateboarders become for a long
time very corporate mainstream
cookie cutter and that's kind of a
bummer like a lot of the best
for a while now a lot of the best
skateboarders kind of just like where's
the fun where's the wild where's the
anarchy where's the punk rock sure
it's still there for sure well look at
green day same thing with punk rock
itself it becomes gap punk sorry
really joe yeah yeah but i mean
definitely dookie was good
but i mean you love dookie again i love
you you listen you listen
always loves dude i love what you said
michael about decentral centralized
government and these because the united
states is kind of decentralized like
states in many ways the cops in a state
can be like get out of here to the feds
if they come and try and bust up their
state laws
and that's very exciting to me that we
yeah i mean you have i think ohio
basically said to the atf like we're not
going to enforce federal
uh gun laws i think west virginia just
passed something similar where they're
all basically saying
even though the atf says that they'll
enforce these laws you can't do anything
about it
i went to the ats website ring about
bump stocks because of this new uh
court ruling that said a bomb stock is
not a machine gun
and they still say no you cannot have it
so
i do find it interesting when california
was
legalized medicinal marijuana the dea
still came in and raided these shops
so it is interesting that you can be in
your state and know that you're safe
from your state basically
the feds still come in yeah i was there
for that in l.a and
that was a big fear a lot of times that
the feds would come and raid one of
those shops
and they did i watched videos of it and
there were times that the local cops
would be like get out of here but i mean
it was the feds yes it's a weird uh
i mean what wait what are your thoughts
because i mean you're coming from a
position of anarchy
i when you have a state say it's legal
to do these things and the feds say
we're gonna come in and bust them up
anyway
i think that's that's wonderful i mean i
think any time you have this kind of
power versus power it just shows you
that
law is a myth and all law means
is whether the what people don't
appreciate is law only works if you have
the will to enforce it
so a lot of times things become legal
not because some politicians went in and
changed the law
but because there was no political will
to enforce the same thing with the
lockdowns
at a certain point it's cuomo said this
i got paid
to read his book and he says in the book
i repeatedly
he says i knew unless i got compliance
from the voluntary compliance from the
vast majority of the population
there was no way i could put this in
place so he's like it was important for
me
to murder the elderly but also to
explain to the population
why we're putting these things into
place so that they would feel
comfortable doing this so this is the
big
uh misconception is that versus 1984
versus brave new world
so much of authoritarianism is not a
function of a gun to your head
like they have in north korea it's a
function of uh the televangelists like
john oliver
and rachel maddow on your tv every night
prothero
yeah of course telling you this is good
people who don't do this are bad and
evil or stupid and
good people behave in a certain way and
then you don't have to have the cost of
enforcing compliance
but then yes don't you think at a
certain point you know we're talking
about leisure
you end up with too much ignorance
weakness laziness
and people this this is i think the
strongest
criticism of capitalism and i've come up
with it and i don't have a good answer
we're this comes from the paleo kind of
uh diet and mindset
if you get to a point where maslow's
hierarchy of needs has been taken care
of meaning
you don't have to worry about where the
next meal is going to come from you
don't have to worry about the roof over
your head
you don't have to worry about your
health really your brain
is still wired to think in terms of
resource scarcity
our brains are still in terms of get
more get more get more and if you don't
actually have
problems in an evolutionary sense where
no predator is going to eat you you have
plenty of food
you have shelter your brain is going
this is my hypothesis
is going to find problems to validate
its emotion
in the same way that depression anxiety
people don't realize this
the emotion comes first the depression
the anxiety then your brain tells you
oh you're depressed because you don't
have a job there's plenty of people who
have a job who aren't depressed
it's just your mind tells you exactly
what it needs to do
to validate this emotion to perpetuate
itself thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you